oh my god hey don't Michael K William
look at that
hug for Jim what's going on man oh you
still that's one of the greatest things
in my life it's time to become one the
highlights of my career bro it's like
I'm doing you a favor
dude you did me a favor people love that
[ __ ] yeah it's on them [ __ ] but thank
you for saying that
ah yeah we're like we didn't curse
that's nice that you said that you know
Michaels talking about when he opened my
I know we were on the air kissing your
ass it's funny it's one of my favorite
things that you did that that's one of
my highlights of my career well I think
it's mine I swear to god someone just
stopped the other day was like dude ask
me how I know what kind of person you
are and it was like oh [ __ ] yeah I get I
have had a couple of unusual openings
I've had that that was one of them that
I get to narrow and one and I had ozzy
osbourne the other so all my favorite
people in this area so yeah you're a
great cop now if I feel honored yes
yours it is one of the ones that helped
me but I asked in order to do it for the
next one I sent yours to go like this is
how we loved it they loved that yeah
they I watched the prior openings and
there was Ozzy and one and you and this
one and I sent them and that was one of
the things that convinced him to
actually do it well he's all legit guys
had done it that's amazing
yeah so I owe you a lot though all of
you already know thank you buddy and you
look really good and you look happy
yeah everybody would do that right yeah
we make for better interviews
yeah people can travel with that now
they don't bother you in the airport
where that I don't think I don't think
so
not yet anyway I don't know I just have
heard they haven't bothered you in there
right right I heard from your own
experience you would have no idea I
would have no idea
fightin whatsoever but people that you
would never associate with you haven't
heard from them know rumor has it
how much fun is like you you you really
every time I see you're happier and
happier and it's like you know since the
wire ended you've done nothing but work
like you literally have done nothing but
work you know what you don't miss been
good on a personal level man like um
number one is on my nephew a Dominic
DuPont who who was incarcerated for you
know for 20 years um he got Clemens by
Governor Cuomo and just came home on
January 28th oh wow so um you know this
is gonna be his first Easter home and
Wow
my mom's is making a huge deal over it
you know I mean and and so uh it's just
you know our family's been reunited I
started a nonprofit organization um mkw
making kids win that he's gonna be him
and my niece are gonna you know helping
me lay the foundation work for the
groundwork for it um you know this
disarm recently wrapped my uh my
documentary alongside um Matt Horwitz
and David Lavin for with Shane Smith um
for HBO was called a a working title is
called diamond in the rough and its
surrounding the criminal the juvenile
criminal justice system of America I'm
super proud of that
so you know like gonna you know I've
been finding my I guess purpose and yeah
yeah you're taking this great thing like
your your acting career you're doing
other stuff with it it's opening doors
for you to a lot of do stuff that you
want to do as a person yeah yes sir yes
sir what were the circumstances that led
to your cousin getting out of jail you
know he did the work you know um his but
no nothing special of having me as an
uncle he did the work he 20 years a
pristine uh a record no incidents how
old when he went in he went in at 18
years old and why four he went in for a
second-degree murder on his twin brother
was being accosted
by a group of men over over girl kids
you know yeah and um he went to defend
his brother it made a bad decision by
taking an illegal firearm to do this but
you know we're from Brooklyn it wasn't
in the projects right so um um that's
what we did and um he went to to defuse
a situation but um it escalated and the
gun went off and unfortunately another
human being lost their life and you know
he spent the next 20 years of his life
in prison but you know he didn't
that doesn't of that moment he's not
defined by that moment he went in as a
young boy and he grew up in there
um got his education got married you
know started Wow programs in there to
help mentor young men coming in behind
him and um did that without ever ever
having one incident not one blotch on
his record who out here in the free
world saying 20 years they haven't had
enough to go in their record house he
meets a girl he married that's amazing
to me because guys in jail are getting
married and I literally can't get laid
on the outside she involved with this
case was it like somebody who knew the
attorney
oh is that a big question that's it
right there
yeah that's amazing man what a great
story I was just thinking like if you go
in you're 18 that means like 20 years
feels like it's a lifetime but you come
out at 38 you haven't in you have more
than a lifetime ahead of you just yeah
that's that's amazing definitely so how
did you meet how did you meet the I'm
amazed by guys who are who are locked up
and who get married how did you meet her
definitely
so actually I knew my wife prior to me
being incarcerated so there was already
a relationship we were friends in the
community and that friendship developed
into a marriage primarily because of you
know understanding the circumstance
that surrounded the incident and her
just saying you know listen you know I
want to be here to support you it grew
into something that I consider just
great you know our relationship has been
phenomenal we're going on 17 years being
married and it's it's program variance
how did you find out you were about to
get out like what what what who told you
hey look they said yes right so so that
was interesting so that started the
clemency process is a very long process
it's the governor essentially saying we
are going to extend mercy and I started
in a few was your sentence was it life
at that parole no so actually my
sentence was 25 years to life I had just
turned 18 years old just our 19 excuse
me when this incident had happened and I
had lost essentially some of my teens in
prison all of my 20s all of my 30s and
actually started my 40s when the
announcement was made by the governor's
office that they were going to grant 61
individuals clemency and 59 of those
people were already in the community
there were two people that one car
serrate it I was one of those Wow and
you and you got the phone call and
what's it like but the time you get the
phone call to the day you walk out are
you panic-stricken that something's
gonna happen there something's gonna go
wrong
they're gonna take it back it's a very
long process you know it's you know it's
something that's very nerve-wracking
because you just don't know what type of
decision the governor will ultimately
make so yeah I was obviously there was
definitely some concerns about you know
you know how things will go but you know
I felt you know safe I had been in
prison like Michael had indicated almost
20 years I served 20 years 7 months 18
days and the announcements were made on
December 27th I was released January
22nd so yeah there was that
you know those few weeks where I was
trying to ascertain like you know you
know what type of services I'll need
thankfully Michael's been very very
helpful 72 hours from our release I was
working for him
I had you know got my ID like hour after
being released that you know we had went
to DMV and you know I was committed to
making sure that I am NOT defined by
that one moment of my life so it wasn't
nerve-wracking absolutely right the
unknown will create that anxiety but you
know thankfully you know we're here
we're doing great work with this
foundation that we're developing right
now and we're continuing to be part of
the solution and no longer part of the
problem you're probably you're probably
the only guy that's had a pleasant trip
to the DMV excited that I was sitting in
traffic like I was like you know this is
phenomenal so when people complain like
around you now you just look at him like
do you know what you have know what this
is you know it's very humbling it's very
humbling to be here today you know my
sentence was a very long sentence a
minimum of 25 years a maximum term of
life in prison and you know you know
like I said this whole process is very
humbling for me and we are committed to
doing the right thing and you guys came
from sorry sandy has been the same I
guess the same where you grew up
together no this is my brother's son
this is my nephew oh that's right oh my
god on the corner from each other I was
there today it happened it was one ocean
and Forester I went to go chop some weed
right I went up I went up Forester I
made a right turn on Rogers Avenue I
made another right turn on wind throb I
stopped I got my we got back at my car I
went to went throughout her to back to
nostra and made another right turn to go
back to the crib to go spark up my time
I got back to notion and forced her it
was it was taped off we're talking like
I mean I left my problem left my block
for 20 minutes if that much I came back
and did that had happened that had
happened one incident changed my
nephew's life for 20 years this boy this
boy's I'm scuse me added when he was a
boy in Bible College there was
no drugs it was no Street activity was
in college it was working both them was
working he just went to defend his his
brother his twin brother and he made a
wrong decision by bringing enough for
any legal firearm to that to that
situation but that's what he was doing
was it going to offend his brothers you
so crazy about that lifestyle though
because like you can be working and
working and working to get yourself out
of it get yourself out if I get yourself
out of it and there's this one little
thing
one momentary thing and it's like now
you're just another statistic boom done
yes right yeah the decision-making right
you right you're here right now and then
the next second next I mean we don't
know what's gonna happen five minutes
from now no we don't right don't know
what's gonna happen five seconds from
there I mean so that's that's what life
is about and only thing we can do is do
the best with what we have and and we're
doing that now yeah and Michael di red
truly did you have a time especially
when you start on the wire or you were
going to you said you were spending your
money and you were doing coke and like
it was it was a lot yeah a lot of drugs
it's hard when you don't have money and
then all of a sudden do you have it you
know
yeah that's not why I could this in
another interview that I equate the wire
with um like with my college years I did
a lot of growing up professionally yes
that was my breakout role and put me on
the map but the personal growth that I
went through know that that took place
that began on the why didn't I didn't
have it all together once the way I was
over in fact the guy it got worse when
the wire ended because um you know that
was my I thought that was my claim to
fame I had no identity I put everything
into that character people were you know
calling me Omar on the street and I was
like yep so what my name is really
Michael you know I was gonna answer Omar
and you know yeah and it just is just
like I got the lines got blurred for me
you know I was like this weight off
something's wrong so when the show ended
it was like okay I have to get back to
me but how do I do that you know and
then you know the the fear of what I
ever work again it was just I just I was
not equipped to deal with you know um
telling a character of that depth and
then to have it end I didn't I was I
didn't know how to deal with that and
and so I did what I do best I got high
you know and um it took it was a long
road to get back to the reality of like
you know well that's not gonna work
anymore but um you know that's why I
look at my life and look at my nephew's
life Madonna's like I'm like you know um
you know we're here for a purpose you
know and I'm looking at you know there's
a reason why he got released at this
moment in my life and he's here with
this mindset and I'm here with my
mindset and you know I'm like okay you
know there's something greater to be
done did you one thing I mean to spoil
if anyone hasn't seen the wire by this
point you know ah you know sorry Candace
Season five it's a you know way they
when they when they killed you off the
wire did they tell you did it really
bought because you said you were so into
that character that did it really like I
hate to see this character die or did
you like the conclusion of it or did you
realize like wow movie like wondering
the same thing like when you're living a
character like you just living that
character in your personal life caring
think I was going on robbing drug
dealers that nature it was the darkness
you know on the heaviness that the
weight that that Omar carried the the
pain that's what I I carried that with
me and I didn't I didn't like
necessarily wash that office it was a
dark space to be and mentally to UM
portray that character and you know and
I thank a grateful that David and and
Edie Nina gave me that opportunity at
that show it saved my life you know it
was me that that I had to get my [ __ ]
together you know I'm grateful I don't
want to be like oh they it you know
that's show I don't mix that the show
was killing me no I was my ignorance was
killing me you know um it was just that
setting yeah it was it was just doing it
in that setting but you know looking
back you know again I was talking on the
other day and David apparently said that
you know he was throwing throwing [ __ ]
at me like um the seed let me see if he
could handle this you don't like like he
was my professor in a sense you know I'm
saying is given me writing that I would
never ever have challenged giving myself
in my life I didn't I didn't excel in
school so he was giving me like
Shakespearean quotes in and Greek
mythology to to say in my lines and do
tell and [ __ ] wouldn't
not gonna learn how to you know work
that didn't make it sound gangster but
but on the wire right and make it fit to
my my palate and in my community and
what I saw and make it believable and
coming out of my mouth whilst was I
gonna get an opportunity like that but
on the wire so like I learned a lot I
learned certain words certain you know
like he made me watch The Wild Bunch and
and what still and then the the bells of
Liberty vow to understand the the the
the doc that the economy of what Omar is
built from like that oh wow Wes when
when when Omar and brother was on had
that standoff yes this caliber this
range you know that's that's that's that
wow I was [ __ ] like like David you know
he it was it was it was a master class
for me and you are you also how hard is
it to like because your career is doing
really well you're always working and
can you talk about the what were you
supposed to do in Star Wars and what
happened that's gotta be a very tough
franchise in solo and solo yes well the
character's name was on his it was a
Dryden box and he was a he was half a
mountain lion half human
he was extremely sophisticated very rich
like he had been around the world old a
guy and he was on and I think it was
sort of a love triangle between Amelia
Amelia Clarke's character Keira and the
young Han Solo not not way it was
overtly a love triangle but there was
definitely some some some some a pissing
contest going on for the girls of
shooting right and he's old and in one
his younger so it was that thing also
going on like young buck I've been I've
been around the world he's like yeah but
the young buck you know the young the
young chick once the young buck yeah so
it was a little bit of that energy going
on but but the relationship was on the
paper was definitely with Kara and Han
Solo but it was definitely there's some
energy going up to Mike
who's in here right so um we shot that
man and um and then I wrapped and then I
went on to Africa to shoot um a red sea
diving resort you know with Kevin Chris
Evans and and the whole gang out there
and then I get the phone call that 80%
into the movie is only 20% left the
shooter in the movie lucasfilm's and and
the directors the brothers for who
directed the the the infamous Legos
movies they didn't see eye to eye
anymore
and were they were fired so um they
bought in um Ron Howard and they said
look we want to see can you steer the
ship back in this direction right and um
how long would it take me to do that he
says give me a few days to assess the
damages and I'll get back to you when he
got back you know in regards to you know
Michael K Williams character you know if
you want me to save that you we're gonna
have to reshoot it in its entirety oh
wow was it they wanted to change certain
elements of how you are yeah I'm
guessing you know it was different it
was you know yeah it was definitely a
difference in direction in in direction
you know the the brothers from Legos
film they I think they were taking the
franchise in a different direction and
what it was not working for Lucas Films
so when there was a better than the day
we create creative differences so at the
end of the day um they were asked to
leave and Ron ha was born in to stare it
back a little in the opposite direction
more along the lines for Lucas films and
that's where the issue came in of my
character being needing needing to be
reshot I was just already on another job
do something else here and so they said
well well we want to keep the release
date the same and and reshoot it how
what would that would take we need to
get him right back right now and that
wasn't gonna did you beg the company or
the production you were doing like a
look just sort of Star Wars franchise
let me or did you just realize you cut
this you know there are certain things
that I've been in Hollywood enough to
know if
that you know just you know anything had
happened right and I've seen a lot of
crazy [ __ ] you know that was one for the
textbooks that I was just so out of left
field there's just some things you know
you know Jimmy's gotta say you know what
it's out of my hands
it's this is out of my hands that is
like a freak accident what are the odds
that that [ __ ] happened right so I just
you know I just saw I accepted it I
accepted that I was exactly where I was
supposed to be I was in Africa and I
wasn't gonna I just wasn't gonna do that
it just didn't make sense it what it
wouldn't have made us a difference a tea
weekend yeah did we were already that
date I was contracted I was there right
that wasn't gonna happen and I just you
know just let it go yeah I guess you
have to it's frustrating to have to pass
up work but you're passing it up for
other work yeah
so we call that rich people problems
yeah by the way happened Leonard is what
Michael is promoting season three is
called the to bear Mambo and it
premieres tomorrow night on sundancetv
at 10:00 o'clock and I guess you can
know that's the same on every whether
it's the same on dish as it is on cables
there's on time water I don't know just
find Sundance T spawn Sundance damn it
Google it [ __ ] yeah exactly and
Michael Kenneth Williams dot-com and
it's a BK BMG on Twitter just to promote
the social media yes sir when you're in
when you're in jail right and and you're
doing you got you you're 20 years in
even if you're one year in six months in
whatever it is like how do you balance
out cuz when we're talking about like
when clemency is even on the table I
would have to imagine that you have to
limit your expectations because you
can't get overly excited about something
because the disappointments just gonna
be way too much so how do you balance
between that and not just being
completely hopeless about everything
because you can't really exist that way
either right that's a good question
thank you I think it's it was simple for
me like my prison was the place of
redemption for me from the beginning
from the beginning it started the moment
the handcuffs got on you know I come
from a very good household you know
Michael's been very supportive he's been
actively involved in my life for all of
my life
including the years that I was
incarcerated and you know I have a very
good support system you know I was a
good kid who made a bad decision and you
know I had to understand that very early
on during my incarceration you know I
realized I did something very wrong and
you know I went to the priests and
turned myself and you know is this
started from the very beginning I'm you
know so where regard to balancing right
you know if you gonna do the right thing
you're gonna do the right thing you're
not looking for you know this came you
know out the blue in a sense you know it
was obviously I wanted to get out of
prison I didn't think I would be getting
out early of course and you know when
you're doing the right thing you know
sometimes good things happen but you
should do the right thing just because
it's right to do not because you expect
meaning that you do the right thing and
then if you don't get the result that
you want that you weren't doing it for
the result anyway you still did the
right thing and that's for the right
reason right I always say that yeah
that's that's where I probably found
wrong I've done average things for
terrible every day every day is another
day another opportunity to get it right
how do you avoid when you when you go to
jail cuz you know I've spent one night
in the tombs it was scary with deborah's
scary downtown I was with another
comedian named Louis black we spent the
night and and and the I remember the
worst thing was I had to [ __ ] and their
little silver bowl doors open I'm like
privacy guys there's 18 of us there was
no toilet paper it was a nightmare and I
just remember this can't be my like I
won't survive here at all I won't do
well how do you avoid when you go to
join how long were you in for one night
the tombs of the weekend oh it's
terrifying
Oh weekend yeah I just realized what an
alpha I'm not there's a guy there was a
guy standing there screaming for a
bologna sandwich and he was yelling at
the guard and I'm like this guy's so
comfortable being here I'll never ever
be comfortable in this world I will
never be able to do that how do you
avoid trouble when you're in jail like
how do you avoid a
I cut you on the line or whatever he
does how do you avoid what you have to
do to protect yourself right so that's a
good question you know there are things
that you can't avoid and then clearly
there are things that you cannot you
know I consider you know just God
looking over me a lot of prayers and you
know I was you know fortunate enough to
be in situations where I mentioned
people I ran into situations where I had
met good men in prison who had also made
bad decisions and also worked really
hard to mentor people but prisoners
prison right yeah I mean we have a lot
of dynamics a lot of challenges and
those are things that you know I've
often you know tried to work on
mediating Michael talked about some of
the things that I was involved in in
prison everything from working with
at-risk youth to being a counselor for
people who were affected and infected
with HIV hepatitis C to working to avoid
conflict by working closely with a group
called the alternative to violence
project so it was those skills that I
use to deescalate situations that could
really get out of control but there were
often times where there were situations
where you know things did get out of
control and at that point you have to be
smart enough to know that if you can't
defuse the situation then step away from
it so in prison often it is either you
fight or flight or you use those
communication skills that you have to
kind of try to for situations of use
what I would I do poorly in jail because
my thing would probably just to threaten
to tell the warden to the guards not
point people out when did you feel like
your career like like you you were you
were on the right path because you just
said like after the wire you were like I
don't know like the wires over I don't
know what this is anymore
like when did you realize like you had a
serious career as an actor that was
going to be just fine bobak Empire that
was it yeah and I realized then you know
I had to get my [ __ ] together I mean you
know it
got you know I started waking up a
little bit with them President Obama
shouted out that he you know he was on
watching the wire and that he took all
my was his favorite character that that
put him I put a spotlight on me that I
never felt before and that made me wanna
kind of you know straighten up but I
still had I was still struggling
personally like massively but when I
booked bulwark Empire I knew it was time
you know I'd be a I had to grow up you
know my sons were getting out of control
with their mom I had to like you know
I'd be a man in their life and uh I just
want I wanted to grow up and I just so I
just I didn't want to screw up what
walking by that I did not want to do you
know so um yeah I thought I started my
venture to grow up a book that show were
you looking every every week at the
script going like alright do I get it
this week or do I not get like you know
cuz we just wound and pork Empire we we
worried because you already been killed
off on showing man was I mean I just do
this you just never know I mean come on
look at look look look at the world
shocked he lived it yes specially season
two with the Klan was around I was like
yeah this is not going to end well
season finale or then the
next-to-the-last made it to the like yes
almost a season finale and which it had
to be super rewarding when people start
calling you chalky instead of Omar
because then you're like oh my god I
made it this is honestly I both were
those names man and they go down in my
history books yes as as equally iconic
though they helped to shake my career
for different reasons and I'm equally as
proud of both that both of those no I
told telling Terry the other day we were
at on an event for a broasted process
I've been on Harlem the organization and
um he I was telling my said you know
after I left bollock Empire I realized
something you know is like oh [ __ ]
there's a whole world out here and you
know I was you know I was raised by HBO
you know I went from basically from
David Simon to to Terry winter you know
with with a little bit of George Woolf
in the middle spring with from George
Woolf and and and Dede Reese you know
that
was practically raised by [ __ ] wolves
you know with new Martin Scorsese I mean
come on I mean this is my this is my
okay I came out the box
working with these people basically and
The Sopranos even a smaller part yeah
bro that but that's the same family that
went on to Berwick Empire
you know Steve Buscemi these are
veterans these are that the
professionalism is is from another era
right and um that's what I was exposed
to very early on in my career and when I
left Boardwalk Empire it was a different
beast out there you know like people
don't shoot on 35-millimeter that was my
career 35 mil yeah me three takes keep
that [ __ ] moving it was you know you
yeah you kept it was expensive you had
to bring a certain a game to the set
there was no time the chit-chattin and
figure it out on the camera you know you
costing people money now man listen you
know I just I don't know I'm just it's
just different animal we have to wrap up
with Michael Travis say we have a minute
left before we let you go obviously pony
happened Leonard the to bear Mambo it
premieres tomorrow night season three on
sundancetv at ten o'clock yes you can
verify it by the way are you happy I'm
extremely happy with this season arm
they're all individually beautiful but I
think this one um we found the niche we
think James and I were in the pocket as
far as our banter our rhythm and our
connection with each other and um we I
mean come over got missed did the
infamous mr. Lou Gossett jr. you know I
mean it's in the story this this year's
an incredibly untimely it was a good
movie with him before we go it was when
he put him in Martin Sheen when he
played the the the new landlord did you
ever see that one where he was in so I
don't remember the name of it I always
spoil interviews by referencing
something no one in the routine but me
don't worry don't worry about not
getting Jim's rest nobody I know I know
gentlemen I'm sure the omen to like
three times a week The Guardian The
Guardian guardian yes that was a damn
good movie yeah Martin Sheen and heaven
he he played like the landlord of the
building and Martin she was the tenant
trying to get rid of him and that the nd
helps March it was a good movie was good
I don't know why I had the record I
couldn't shut up it but Travis said the
Guardian and I kept going yeah there's
no instinct